welcome back to the corridor cast you
guys may have thought that we stopped
doing podcasts but that is untrue we
just got busy making other videos and
now we're back it's good to be back
how you guys feeling good one of the
whole day coloring and by the way these
are dropping tomorrow we got these
little little doohickeys these little
these trinkets yeah we've got these
where's we got these sick sweatshirts
with a sick design on the back yeah
remember that remember the shirt I'm
wearing we got this dd Styles dress so
anyway we're super excited about these
the prints came out great
awesome yeah they're dropping tomorrow I
can't wait to wear these I we had I
really wanted these shirts so I
convinced Jake to stock all of them so I
can get one of each she stalked every
single one my first tie dye shirt
yeah actually wrist of the Ren Faire and
be a cool man I'm still sporting that
green hoodie with the yeah yeah hoodies
ever made uh but wow what a what a month
it's been since we've been on the
podcast and busy we've got a lot of good
got a good topics today apparently we're
going to the moon we're never coming
back
at this table no last week NASA released
videos that was titled we are going and
all it says is that we're going to the
moon by 2024 to stay with a new system
called the Space Launch System which is
designed to do all kinds of things but
basically to use the moon as a jumping
off point for humanity creating a
repeatable strategy to allow for future
exploration on to Mars and the rest of
the solar system so my main question is
like is this actually gonna happen
because it's got 10 million views on
YouTube but anytime that happens I feel
like
the kony2012 so they're gonna drop em on
on like a moon base down I'll believe ya
they're gonna have an orbiting it's
gonna have an orbiting launch platform
that orbits around the moon and then
from there they're gonna be able to do
multiple missions back and forth to the
surface and then basically this model
they they're gonna want to use this this
model of doing the exploration this way
to use that basically from Mars and and
further out into the solar system that's
the idea I feel like we see one of these
videos every time a new president comes
into office like George W Bush that'd be
on the moon by 2020 clearly that's not
happening I guess we should Christian
can you go back a few frames that guy
had a helmet on and be keep going back
and there right there yeah this guy
coming up look at his helmet this helmet
Paul actually kind of sit for going to
the moon multiple times and they've made
multiple videos like this and nothing
quite happens I mean we went once twice
how many times did we go red you know
these facts or seven okay
but it's important to note that
especially for this right now this isn't
exactly NASA's fault for us not getting
there is it's Congress not funding it
right hey you should do all this extra
stuff and it's gonna cost a crap to the
money all right cool all right where's
the money like oh sorry we're not gonna
actually give it about that yeah the
thing so is this is this actually like
an as apiece or is this rather this is a
current administration making this but
like he's published on the NASA YouTube
page Alyssa's budget gets a considerable
bump is the chances of this are low do
you think the president gets the YouTube
passwords to all the government YouTube
channels like the football that they
carry around it's just one you know the
nuclear code for a while was zero zero
zero zero zero zero well I did hear that
yeah it's more like a solid like eight
years he's a trick of that ones you have
to remember how many zeros it
no because there is less there are
people that are arguing like in the case
of nuclear war you do on a complicated
password you want to be easy to launch a
nuclear missile another people like your
of frickin nuts and I would agree with
them you know want to be easy to launch
a nuclear missile also I feel like
that's the point you should not have it
be easy it should be very hard but
there's a whole period of time like okay
well at some point we'll reset the
default password but it's currently zero
zero zero zero zero so not my job to
reset it and that's what it was for a
long time also did you know how did you
so Chernobyl came out in HBO and I've
been doing every time I watch an episode
I spent about an hour afterwards reading
Wikipedia really yeah it's so I gotta
watch this show it's really good first
episode last night and it completely
blew my mind it's like
earth-shatteringly like there's so much
doom and doom like whatever you describe
it like that is numb I was sheer amount
of denial going on like in the moment
yeah it's like just ignoring facts in
your face and I imagine a whole the
whole city pretended it wasn't happening
in front of them as it's happening as
it's happening like guys are picking up
like blocks of radioactive carbon is
graphite and just like oh and then you
like to put sit down and kind of like
shakes his hands like oh my hands gonna
now be dead in like an hour after that
and he was actually actually basic I
love where this is going because I'm
really into ternal right now I'm gonna
drop some facts on you guys push off
radioactive radioactive poisoning it
doesn't kill you right away instead it
destroys your DNA your cells can't
replicate and therefore your body dies
cell by cell over the next two to six
weeks wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
though that intense level though
actually does start breaking down the
cells and you get a hemorrhaging
internal hemorrhaging and that's how you
die if you if you reach a certain
threshold of radiation right destroys
your DNA yeah so that what does that
even mean
so like the radioactivity shooting out
little bits of atoms and the atoms are
flying through your body like little
bullets as they would say in the show
yeah and those little bullets literally
destroy your DNA I mean your cell isn't
just like keep a DNA in every
your DNA is basically on the molecular
structure bullets through your DNA
string it's like a so mm-hmm when hit
with radiation is like getting a
vasectomy essentially that cell can no
longer reproduce hmm and it's it's still
fine for now ish until like the
radiation gets intense and actually
starts killing all the internal organs
of each cell but it's like yeah I mean
but the guy picking up that graphite
block in his hand like falling apart
like five minutes later that's for
dramatic effect well I've read up I read
up I actually research this the one
thing that's been on my Wikipedia hole
afterwards that's for dramatic effect
but the sunburn is real yeah organs huh
cells have organs yeah organelles I mean
like what's the powerhouse of the cell
they might have come out it's not
actually a powerhouse of the cell
because my biology teacher was also my
track coach that's how that works but
but it's crazy so like yes you guys keep
watching the makeup by the way for these
people dying of radiation sickness is so
well done it's so so awful yeah I'm only
two episodes and I still have yet to see
the third one like everybody talks about
these days like especially like if
you're reading like on reddit or
something I'd be like yeah nuclear power
it's not a big deal why does everybody
protest it it's so safe and it's a smart
solution it's like yeah it does seem
safe like even in the biggest accidents
like in Chernobyl only 28 people died
from radiation exposure that's not that
bad
well I guess there's some people that
got cancer afterwards like and that's
the worst accident history why are wives
already protesting nuclear reactor like
nuclear power so she can certain how
many people died in coal mining
accidents you know that Dwarfs number of
people that die from radioactivity and
then you watched her Noble and you go oh
that was thought I would far far far
better than I had any right to because
the real reality of true Noble is that
they could have wiped out all of Eastern
Europe because of that radioactive
meltdown fell into the groundwater it
would have wiped out the entire river
system which would have wiped out all
the farmland and they would have to have
relocated millions of people and like
yeah just it would've been bad we would
have been lost an entire portion of a
continent if that got messed up so
firstly when a meltdown happens that's
basically the the people that are
running the reaction are on a
to control it so the reaction is just
continuing without them being able to do
anything right is that correct so
nuclear reactor works by having fuel
rods which are a radioactive element and
those the uranium fuel rods here are
basically shooting out little particles
and what happens is if you contain that
enough those little particles come back
and hit other uranium elements and they
keep splitting and you get fission
nuclear fission and that creates heat
you use that heat to turn water into
steam and then you spin a turbine with
that steam now these graphite rods that
they have well actually not graphite
rods they're boron Graphite's what
causes the the reaction to go up because
it bounces the the pieces back and forth
more and makes the basic contains the
reaction boron absorbs it and so that's
how you control it so I'd say it's
getting too hot you drop some boron in
there around these rhenium rods and that
absorbs these particles and doesn't let
them bounce back and kick off more you
little uranium bits it doesn't cause
more fission now they were testing what
would happen if we need to
oops my microphone one weird yeah
they're saying okay what would happen if
we have like we lose power or some like
that like they're testing out having to
drop the control rods and stuff like
that okay
so what's gonna happen is we're gonna
start lose power when that happens we're
going to start to lose some coolant and
that's all to be expected and so when
that happens we're gonna drop in the
control rods which will prevent the
reaction going crazy now the hand
anticipated is on the ends of those
control rods they had graphite which is
what they use to make the reaction go
higher and that's that was for
efficiency because when the control rods
aren't in the reactor they still on that
graphite there on the ends to help the
reaction go and so they're going through
this test and the things that's a power
down as planned they switch over to the
generators keep the turbine spinning as
planned so okay now we're gonna have the
power spike cool that's normal
all right now we gotta drop the control
rods and they did that but the problem
is that graphite tips in the control
rods as a control add started to drop
the graphite tips caused a spike because
the graphite tips went in first and it
spiked and it spiked really high it
spiked to the point where the power
output of that like that second was the
power output of the entire state of New
York for one year and then when that
happened the control rods cracked and
when the control rods cracked they
couldn't go down any further
all right and then we went from there
and it got real messy yeah it seems like
a lot easier solution would be just to
build a dam and send some water through
a dam but then would you move some
turbines all the people downriver who
something lose their water I mean it's
better than drinking poison it's true
it's true now a nuclear reactor is not
nearly as dangerous as a soviet-era RPK
reactor right yeah they really messed up
Nevers like tell me how does our RP ake
a reactor explode it was like I have no
idea but it did dang well sounds like I
gotta watch this it's really good it's
really getting days now so do you guys
think we'll go to the moon to stay by
2024 that's only four years it's now
that seems like there's no way it's
happening I'm sorry
that seems I love space as much as
everybody else I mean to a certain
degree a lot of that is just to get the
ball moving even if it's not like you
set these really ambitious goal posts so
that you can get your button gear even
if you know like in the bag your hand
you're not actually gonna finish yeah
but without that you may not have been
nearly as far by the end of it how many
you guys thought space shuttles are cool
back in the day the space shuttles are
every thought space shuttles are cool
they are cool well did you know they're
not apparently like their officials are
example of like designed by committee
where they can't do anything well and
they're like really expensive and you
know two of them blew up yeah right it's
true the Challenger blew up and the
clothes at the Columbia on re-entry fell
apart so how would you design a space
shuttle you know the thing is they want
to make it like this plane that I could
fly back in but making it a plane made
it not a very good rocket and like to
leave the atmosphere you need a good
rocket and you don't really need a plane
to get back into the atmosphere so this
whole idea of being a reusable like
space plane thing didn't work at all and
you just had a really poorly designed
rocket that's what they were what they
were trying to do was just to do the
reusability aspect like oh yeah cheaper
if we're able to send it up fly it back
down then we could just fly it up again
but the problem is that they had all the
fix's they would have to do every time
it landed ended up costing like
something like one to two billion
dollars every single time I mean it is
like at that price we could have just
built a whole nother shuttle what are
they doing these days they don't have
any cent indeed the shuttle program
years ago
there's no way yeah it's SpaceX with
their rockets that are landing right now
there's in the future there's no way for
America to get an astronaut into space
right now on our own really have a way
to get anybody into space that does not
seem like send our astronauts to Russia
for a country country that prides itself
on space defense that seems like a very
poor defense strategy yeah well no we're
working on ways I mean the United States
government can't put a man in space
right now they can't we have zero ways
to put anybody into space my god they're
working on it what do we do this
mistakes aren't quite as high as what I
think you're making of course it's like
of course there already is like space
agencies that have a workflow for us to
get astronauts in the space we've been
doing it for decades now it's not really
a problem it's just expensive so NASA is
exploring alternate possibilities
through Boeing and SpaceX to send
astronauts to space and right now SpaceX
is gonna be probably the first one to do
it they had a test to send their their
dragon capsule into space that's gonna
carry astronauts but it blew up in a
test like a few weeks ago and they
haven't really explained what really I'm
not here about that allayed everything
for the rest of the year so we're not
gonna work the goal is that we're gonna
be actually putting astronauts in the
space so if there's an emergency just
hear me out on this hypothetical there's
an emergency we need to put a man in
space we can't go to the Russians or
whoever else can put people in space
currently we need to do it so they call
Elon Musk and they're like dude we need
to put a man in space now and he goes
well the last pod that I had it was a
test the test function and they're like
we're willing to take the chance
I mean it's all just risk analysis right
it's like right now NASA has such a huge
high threshold for like or lowering for
risks to make sure that you know there's
triple and quadruple redundancies so
that nothing to blow up it wasn't even a
test launch I think they're doing a test
static fire of some of the engines on
the thing in it in then some sort of
detonation happened and at least I
haven't heard any explanation for it yet
hmm
because when you read your birthday they
did the capsule test launch was that it
yeah that was a good launch that one
worked out yeah except they lost the
main engine on the way back it didn't
land correctly I mean yes sir so that's
just a SpaceX thing where they're trying
to land the rockets and what are the
three didn't land like very beginning of
more but I think Sam send enough well um
if we currently don't have a way to get
anybody into space in four years
probably not gonna be on the moon yeah
it supports that statement yeah right
now they're trying to use what NASA's
rocket system is right now is called the
SLS system yeah big basically just a
big-ass rocket right and it's
unfortunately incredibly expensive
because I think you kind of mentioned
that there's all these different factors
all these different companies in play
with middlemen and that everyone's
trying to make a profit so that kind of
blooms the the price of all these things
and delays and it's just like it's it's
already way behind schedule and way over
budget
yeah this is still what NASA's like
we're still gonna be using this yeah and
there's with is rockets that can land
after they take off yep no NASA is what
right things with with their rockets
it's like NASA's a big fan we'll get to
let's go to something that's actually
happening by 2024 that's Mike divas new
Lonely Island unauthorized bash brothers
experience guys this just dropped our
buddy Mike Deva directed it this treater
of date Peter Pan France worked on the
effects our buddy Peter 42 yeah who else
worked on the effect [ __ ] steak man
yeah come talk even chancer yeah who you
might remember from our node cabin
videos Big Bear videos so this is pretty
great because you got Jose Canseco and
mark mcgwire the bash brothers yeah aka
the bash bros using a series of six
music videos wait wait these are I
wondered about authorization from the
athletic the Oakland A's did not are
they parroting actual baseball players
yes so in the early 90s the bash
brothers was a was a duo in case you
guys were born after 1990
[Laughter]
every time they'd hit a home run they go
like this oh yeah
and that's why they were known as the
bash brothers because they just they
were they were they were basically they
were pumped up on stairs together
because you're like yeah can we try it
over here since they're trying it
it's a forearm X pattern yeah I guess
their arms were full of steroid
basically of steroid use in baseball was
like the late 80s and early 90s and
these guys were like the epitome of it
now entertaining as hell to watch but
but Wow so these guys somehow managed to
take that as source material for a movie
yes it's a 30-minute long visual poem
it's a 30-minute long visual poem it's
distractive short film basically what it
is is Andy and Akiva from Lonely Island
wrote a bunch of songs based on the bash
brothers music and they're like are like
a piece of this and Mike had actually
done the visuals for their concert and
they approached Mike's like Mike well
you co-direct this with me said Akiva
and Mike was like you bet your ass hell
yeah I will and so they shot all these
music videos Mike basically had to
finish like six music videos in a month
yeah and so he's been buried he wasn't
living in his office I visited him a
couple times in this process I got to go
to said actually from a box if you watch
this is like there's a press briefing
like couple scenes and this and I was
gonna be one of like the reporters but I
had a friend coming in the town so I had
to leave to leave me for her I got to be
filmed but I did I didn't you know get
to watch Mike and Akiva work their magic
and I talked to Andy Samberg a little
bit and I'd always been curious in
Christian if you wouldn't mind pulling
this up on YouTube here just like a like
hotrod stunts any Samberg is the guy
from Brooklyn nine-nine you're the one
who only on guys SNL I mean he's pretty
famous guy yeah really nice guy actually
we were talking like so all everybody
was off filming in on the stage and I I
was by myself so I was leaving and Andy
was just sitting in his chair watching
the stuff on the monitor and I was like
you know how are things going with Mike
he's all yeah it mike is great it's been
awesome like I'm really glad you picked
up he's like yeah he's really been
transforming this thing into something
cool and I have a question for you
there's a stunt and hot rod where a guy
tries to jump a trailer and he goes down
a ramp and he hits this ramp and the
ramp breaks and he flies over the
trailer and he slams into the other side
of the ramp and then onto the ground and
this is like watching this like knowing
stunts like this is one heck of a stunt
it's not a dummy like you can tell us
not a dummy
but for us something had to take the hit
I'm like man this is such a very
intricate and hard hit to take whoo so I
asked Andy like how did you do this
stunt the guy just like freaking eat it
he's like yeah so it's an incredible
stunt so he's on a bike about to go over
just a van in a neighborhood yeah
there's two jumps on either side of a
van he's gonna go over the van and down
the other and Wow oh my god so basically
the guy flies off the first jump as the
first jump collapse it was odd he barely
clears the van
she is like and then he slams into the
edge so what was supposed to happen in
the first ramp collapses you see it
collapse there BAM
it's supposed to collapse Spurs are just
supposed to hit the side of like this
little trailer of this truck it's like I
just came to our post office truck so
guys just supposed to hit the side of
that that was the plan
instead he clears it and he hits the
edge at the ramp on the other side and
he hits it with his femur and he cracked
his femur and a half oh yeah there's
this femur hitting it happened like
everybody on set went quiet and just
like oh no and like they you know called
an ambulance the shoot was canceled for
the rest of the day guys he was fine
after you know his leg healed but it's
just like it was definitely a stunt I
have had a funeral but I got my answer
it was it turns out just like that crazy
cliff jump in that Naruto Rock Iraqi
video this is just somebody effing
themselves up and it captured it on
camera funny how many times that stuff
makes it in yeah I mean that's if I was
a stunt man and I [ __ ] myself up I
would want ya in the movie I mean
there's a guy gets around the truck and
turny or two and cracks his head on the
pavement pretty good and yeah so anyways
that was my experience that's cool I'm
glad Andy Samberg seems like a nice guy
he's a really nice guy I've been a huge
fan very long time I mean they're kind
of the original viral music guys yeah my
freshman year of college was when I'm on
a boat came out yeah it was like the
anthem of my entire like school year oh
dude yeah absolutely
I remember Washington on the channel on
a1 back in the day my stuff I don't know
if you guys remember channel 101 but
yeah crazy channel above 100 I have a
Dalmatian for every channel Justin
roiland got a starting channel one alone
too
really yep alright like a breeding
ground for a bunch of comedians that
have now made a big when that on YouTube
channel one one was before YouTube is
basically you would make videos and go
to a theater and like you'd gather
around and be like
many Film Festival and then the audience
would vote for who gets to continue
making stuff oh well and like the person
who gets the least amount of oats gets
kicked off the island or what I mean you
just where did they post the videos on
the internet
I'm channel 101.com okay this is website
status yeah I don't even know if it's
still up but yeah Wow
yeah a little history for you see if
it's still there channel 101 live like
the very first lonely island videos are
on there oh wow there it is catch the
magic guys The Bachelor but with dads
screening 8:00 p.m. and 10:00 p.m. at
the Downtown independent that's like
five minutes away from us oh it's still
going I guess it's still going wow yeah
though with YouTube around I mean look
at these videos 127 views 298 views I
guess YouTube really took the steam out
of their sails Wow is that saying taking
the steam out of your sails wind out of
your sails all of like the crazy energy
generating technology we have it all
almost always boils down to just like
hey pond water to turn something yeah
like literally just having anything turn
and spin in a circle has been like the
way to produce energy for hundreds of
years and what will there's probably not
circles what next I mean do you think
that meant fusion in our lifetime I hope
so
no I hope so I hope so too that's self
contained energy that's how is that even
a sickly saucisson self holding hands
that's not even physically pastas it is
it's fusion not fission fusion yeah
itself continues like self-supporting
self-supporting it's not no it's not
perpetual energy all right guys ready
for radiation quick tip I'm digging this
direction
fission energies when you split an atom
fusion energy is you can combine an atom
yeah in the center of the Sun is where
fusion occurs under the intense pressure
and gravity of the entire Sun and the
heat and so you get atoms that form
together and that's how you get other
elements in the hydrogen because
hydrogen is just one proton one neutron
one electron so how do you get solid a
for example helium which I believe is
for right or is it - yes so - might be
right which is two protons two neutrons
and two electrons and that you only get
helium by combining two hydrogen's yeah
so if fusion reaction is when you
combine these things and gives you a lot
of energy you can use like you can use
hydrogen as fuel and there's a lot of
hydrogen it's the most prevalent element
in the universe we also have a lot of
water here on the planet so you can use
some of that hydrogen for fuel the Sun
is mostly hydrogen and if you're to add
up the Sun plus all the planets and all
like the rock debris in the entire solar
system the Sun would make up something
like 99.5% of all the mass in the solar
system hmm Wow yeah yeah it's cool but
the problem with fusion is that when you
combine the atoms and you get that
reaction it creates a plasma that's
super hot hotter than anything else can
hold it like there's nothing strong
enough to hold this plasma so I can just
make a really strong steel bucket it'll
melt through the bucket that's not good
yeah so what they're trying to come up
with is like an electromagnetic field
that can like contain this applies when
they get float in a vacuum where it
doesn't touch anything
it doesn't sound safe there's a here
type in 20 minutes if I took a droplet
of this yeah yeah through it it would
burn and then it'd go out so yeah but it
could burn through anything Chris will
you type in stellarator that's too big
it's like oh really hey we took away
some blankety-blank on this like a piece
of plasma comes off of a fusion reaction
and then it starts burning through
everything and no one can stop Rhodes
most dangerous power plant hottest
lollipop
so they've come up with these designs to
try to contain the plasma and they have
like this basic donut design the problem
was class when the outside gets cooler
as it's moving slower supplies when the
inside you have dragon so you need to
keep a plasma at the same temperature
and they came up with the design using
fluid dynamics or it's like the spinning
field like if you click them like the
bottom left there like you see the
difference between the like the torah'
tokamak versus the stellarator so those
are basically magnets controlling the
plasma but you need to have it to the
plasma it's like fluctuating both in the
inside and the outsides and rotating on
each other so using fluid dynamics the
curated in 3d modeling they created what
the magnets would need to look like
around a ring of plasma that's twisting
on itself and so they've that's the
tokamak on the left they're the basic
old boring which will never work and
that's a stellarator on the right and
you couldn't make that until you had
computers and it's really cool looking
and then pushing right above it there's
a picture the actual thing what look at
that
so the plasma spins around a bunch of
the magnets until it cools down until it
cools down it's just they they need to
hold the plasma in this vacuum but in it
like you know it's spinning I guess
around a center point but it spins it
spins in the vacuum forever
well no not forever not forever it's
just more that like you need to have the
plasma be uniformly hot and when you
have like just something's being a
circle something on the inside is
spinning at a different rate than
something on the outside and so they're
coming up with a way where they can like
just have the fluid twisting on itself
right so over that really fluid the
plasma twisted on itself so that's kind
of staying uniformly hot and moving in
uniformly speeds better uniforms I'm
saying like eventually you would want to
cool it down right I mean we stopped
feeding it fuel and energy the moment it
stops reacting oh so you do this during
the fusion reaction yeah to sustain that
plasma burn I see wow this makes me feel
like I'm not doing anything with my life
we're discovering energy sources that
can you be utilized by humanity forever
if everyone was discovering and creating
power sources for humanity then like
what good would that be energy into the
air whoever came up with the first joke
would make a lot of money yeah
the kind what's with these headphones I
think it's just the is this one of our
connections yeah that's fine being funky
one of the things that was like almost
all of human advancement is tied to
energy surplus right first you have food
surplus farming which lets us do other
things and spend our time doing other
things that's an energy surplus for
human beings you know the oil like first
coal for example then oil having these
energy sources which are cheap gives us
another cheap energy energy surplus and
you've seen what we've been able to do
with oil and coal Industrial Revolution
imagine having literally free
electricity we could have our computers
running all the time renders for EM
savers wouldn't exist renders everywhere
air-conditioning at full blast all day
cars limitless miles per gallon I'm
obviously a huge fan of solar in the
idea because once you get to a certain
point where solar panels are gonna
become so cheap it basically becomes a
free utility mm-hmm if you just project
out the math right now it's like it
it'll eventually get cheap enough that
like you can basically just be free um
but then I'm reading this book series
called the expanse right now I'm on like
book 5 or 6 that Amazon show that uh
people didn't want it to be cancelled
right yeah it's a good show too but I'm
still like so much into the books and
there's this thing in one of the later
books where a catastrophe happens on
earth we're basically an asteroid hits
the earth and it covers the whole
blanket the whole planet in like clouds
and dust and all this stuff and this is
a super futuristic society like 350
years in the future and suddenly all of
their solar panels no longer work like
right yeah if everyone goes to solar all
it takes is one catastrophe like that
and suddenly no one has any more power I
guess you'd want to diversify a little
bit right yeah well they also have
fusion so it's not like super bed
oh yeah reactors everyone does have
solar panels on the roof all right
speaking of factories and energy and all
that stuff there was a there was a
published dirt there was a publication
that was released by the US National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
recently that I think this week that
discovered a sharp rise in
chlorofluorocarbon gases or CFCs in the
atmosphere last year despite a global
ban on their use since the Montreal
Protocol of 1987 when it was discovered
that CFCs contributed to creating a
giant hole in the ozone layer so this
study has pinpointed the source of the
CFCs as coming from northeastern China
finding increased emissions from that
region specifically but not from Japan
the Korean Peninsula or any other region
in the area leaving them to assume or
infer rather that there must be
factories producing or using CFCs in
northeastern China yeah so your solvent
fix are you guys do you guys believe it
oh yeah I do
I mean it's not really a belief kind of
situation ya know Sam makes a very good
point there's nothing to believe here we
have evidence in facts dang so ok so
what why what can be done about this the
only thing that can be done is for the
people of China to have a cultural
change that makes them think it's more
valuable to protect the environment than
it is to make cheap products right but
in an yeah I know you're right fact that
applies to everyone on the planet yeah
if you're buying the cheapest things at
Amazon from China you're kind of
contributing to the problem yeah like
it's also worth noting that China is
making the heart the biggest push
towards renewable energy and trying to
save the environment
in most countries on the planet are they
yeah that's true because then why are
they allowing stuff like this to happen
it's a big country it is huge 1 point
whatever billion people and and a lot of
stuff kind of just I really just do it
I'd really like to see the evidence
behind a statement like that because
I've heard it
echoed in many places you know that
China is taking broader steps but uh
well like their installation of solar
for instance is way higher and way
faster than anyone else okay their
adoption of those newer technologies
they're making bigger pushes towards
electrification yep
yeah we saw of situations like this too
but they are also still the biggest
polluter in the world
yeah they are definitely that by a long
shot we know these problems will get
fixed instantly it's certainly like
China has seen the extremes of pollution
now and I feel like because that they're
more motivated than anyone else didn't
fix the pollution III do agree on that
standpoint because there was the like
the smog crisis basically in 2008 or
whatever in Beijing in Beijing yeah yeah
and all these stuffs around got a lot
worse since then well how do you know
I'm just saying like that's when it was
like the that's what it became aware
yeah became like a thing the rest of the
developed world the thing about the
weird thing about China and correct me
if I'm wrong on the rest of the rest of
the developed world is generally run by
this combination of democracy and
capitalism and so in a country that's
not run like that how do you what forces
because here you could say well market
forces will take care of it eventually
right or like you know democracy will
take care of it eventually something
will happen yeah right but in there how
do you say like well eventually they'll
stop doing this well arguably the forces
would would would push that arguably
though that would still that occur at
some point though like my my observation
is a very is just like not academically
the weeds yeah preface but when I see
other countries developing I see them
kind of following a similar pattern and
to me like China was going through what
like America went through in the 30s in
the 20s like they went through that 20
years ago and so now we're kind of
seeing China hit the 50s and 60s and 70s
where you have a much more modern
industrial era but you're now you're
getting into the beginnings
of environmental regulation like when
America went through that in the 60s and
70s you're seeing China go through that
now and give it another 10 years channel
probably where America's at in 80s so
expect a lot of like funky synthesizer
music in like a lot of people don't
realize or maybe just forget that the
smog in LA used to be so much work
yeah yeah yeah way worse than it is now
yeah yeah everyone always thinks of LA
is like a very smoggy city and it does
have smog but it's like nothing compared
to where it used to be yeah like just in
the cities well you look at that like
you look at that old truck that I have
uh-huh
that thing is just the worst with
gasoline like if everyone was driving
one of those on the road every single
day that would just be like of course it
looked like that because you can't get
new trucks until everybody's driving
those trucks first because right first
things first is everybody's has to get a
truck and then once you have a truck you
have a little more capacity to be more
productive and then we get a little more
productive and you have more of
environmental people on cars and I can
start making new trucks and surplus
you're talking about and it's just it's
a process and it takes the same path and
the same amount of time kind of
everywhere and that's just the thing
I've noticed it's like every place kind
of follows the same trajectory you know
so you think that the forces of change
in and of themselves will eventually
yeah I mean the forces that really drive
everything is human nature and yeah
there's capitalism and there's democracy
but at the core of it is human nature
and we're not all that different from
each other so no anticipate it's not
like anyone wants to live in a world
that's burnt and horrible for you yeah
usually I get there a little bit but you
know that's the thing too is when you're
when your entire country is living in
poverty and you're just starting to
modernize you don't really care too much
about how much co2 you're putting out
there especially when like you don't
even access to like vaccines and clean
drink yeah yeah it's like telltale the
dude who's running the factory that's
you and these chemicals out who's like
for the first time not living in some
Hut yeah you know concrete box to stop
I'll probably be like no especially when
you already crossed that point where you
already did alright like we already did
all our polluters like
and Silicon Valley
he goes to they go all the way to China
to tell him to stop competing with them
like stealing their stuff and he just
goes no it's easy to like talk about
like reducing your carbon emissions when
you already have your air conditioners
in your cars
oh yes apartment yeah you know when
you're just literally still going out
and like scraping up dirt to like grow
your planes okay so but like would you
then give every country in the world a
pass for that it's not a passive search
that's the process you have to getting
to the higher like higher technology
advancements of like renewable energy
you can't get there until you have roads
no what I mean by passed though it's
like I think you bring up more of a an
ethical question than at that point
which is like how many what what's
Earth's capacity for modernized the
nation's if modernized nations have to
go through this I guess period as you
would describe it because I feel like
given like what we know about the
current climate of the planet I think
you would probably say that we're
already bumping up against that
threshold so how far would you let it go
like how many it's like it's there
anything after China where we would
allow to get that far or how do you stop
it you know I mean you're looking at
China and India right now is being like
the big up-and-coming country I mean
that's the question how do you yeah
can't really stop it because you can't
stop it when it's not likely all
governments are you know like there's no
world police
so might be you know it's like you know
it's not like we're gonna do sanctions
against a country that uses coal you
know or will we will we get there maybe
eventually but I think it you know at
the end of the day it's really just how
much how important is it to you like can
we all survive making five percent less
of our income yes we could all survive
making five percent less than our income
if that's what it took to change carbon
emissions and fix it and you know in
America if we if everybody took a five
percent hit is that like is that
important enough to us to do that I'm
just making up numbers here by the way
but like that's the question have to ask
yourself
like at which point how much are you
willing to pay how much you willing to
sacrifice to fix these things because
that's the reality what's going to be is
if you want to protect the environment
it makes things less efficient and makes
things less yeah
you know it makes it more expensive it
depends it depends it depends on what
process you're curbing I don't think
that's a like a general as a general
statement well maybe it is a job it is a
yeah like it is fundamentally though to
be responsible with waste and resources
that is inefficient for certain purposes
you know like if your purpose is to make
it tire and but you have to deal with
these certain protocols that require you
to get it in a certain place that
require you to deal with the waste and
the the pollutants that are created in
the process in a certain way obviously
that's less efficient than just taking
them putting them in 50 gallon drums and
setting them outside of your factory
yeah yeah yeah I mean of course I mean I
don't think it's the efficiency I mean
efficiency is what civilization is yeah
you know and like working on those
problems is like yeah what simulation
what civilization kind of does so I
would yeah it's not like it's a question
of short-term versus long-term times
there's times when it's appropriate to
be short-term yeah yeah definitely and
then you can start looking long-term but
like I guess another thing to consider
is like would there's got to be money in
it for somebody somewhere you know
because like ultimately even in China
that's still that's still the driving
force behind like the decision to even
start a factory you know is like well
I'll make money if I do it and - how do
you get to a point where it's like well
I'll make money if I clean it up or
you'll make money just by obeying the
law you'llyou'll that's your best option
you know like I don't know yeah until
until resources are plentiful people
can't make sacrifices really at the end
of the day that's my observation like
when everybody is making a decent income
then you can start talking about okay
we're gonna put a little bit of a
pump the brakes a little bit on your
prophet or until they're affected
personal like most people right aren't
gonna care about climate change until
they're affected hurt like personally
and for us in today's era what that
comes out as is in the form of like
flooding and hurricanes or forest fires
and no no kind of stuff where it's like
oh wow we've had a lot of really bad
hurricanes lately it's like yes what's
going on and that's just every
trajectory is saying that's getting
worse and worse so as more and more
people are affected more and more people
are you know noticing that like oh yeah
this is affecting me and even though I
might not have a whole lot of wealth I I
want to do something about this and for
most people they've not been affected
yet yeah but I think we're gonna see a
lot more of that I think there's another
issue too in that I feel like a lot of
people have taken to like so many not
missing people but yeah I guess people a
lot of people use that as marketing for
their products or it's like oh this is
environmentally friendly and like the
whole sense of doing something for the
environment has gotten so bogged down in
people they having the image of doing
something for the environment that's
hard to tell if you're actually doing
something for the environment when you
like you're going to shop at a
restaurant has sustainable locally grown
whatever like it's actually helping the
environment or is that marketing in like
your head you have this fog of like what
could you actually help like the fog of
luring plastics new recycling bin
doesn't necessarily help the environment
most that plastic is ending up in the
dump or being burned anyways yeah it was
now they're not it's India yeah yeah I
watched a TED talk doesn't actually get
recycled really yeah most of most of our
recycling just gets literally just
postage Dover to uh because that's the
cheapest way to deal with it we don't
have a city to deal with it here so we
have to get rid of it so there's no
money for them to melt it down resell it
they just get cheap plastic materials
from us and use it for what they can and
then that's that the end right I guess
the secondly recycled once this is what
I'm saying though about the financial
like interest if there was some interest
in like now
doing that well the problem is I figured
you'd have it you'd have more
cultivation of this recycling of the
resource the the the idea of the
financial interest is interesting and
also really tricky because I I did look
up something we were discussing before
we started recording which was uh we
were talking about the way way phones
yeah and kind of like this relationship
we have with like China and Asia and I
was looking at the idea or I was looking
at what happened with the steel in China
basically and how steel production over
the last decade was subsidized well not
decade I think even longer but he's yeah
basically being subsidized by the
Chinese government
to create stuff there at home but then
basically they ended up with an
overproduction that still is being
subsidized and what that is doing it's
that it is adversely affecting like US
Steel and you know righted states
companies and so I think it's a really
good example though of you know what
like the one pitfall of basically
attributing solutions to market forces
is because we're living in this world
where like that there's this
international inflation and deflation
that that is abnormally affecting you
know the quote unquote market price or a
market force that should be driving some
like renewable thing cycling or why is
there why did there become a surplus of
steel and China is because they made a
ton to make steel products subsidized it
and because it was subsidized there by
the Chinese government
so like multi million contracts are
being in tax benefits write-offs etc for
Chinese steel companies and so that
basically drive down the price and has
wiped out a lot of the steel work but
what I'm saying the reason why so many
people flooded that market why there's
so much of a surplus it was they put a
subsidy out there the ouch made it more
profitable to make steel in that area
which is why now there's there's a
surplus of it so there's still there's
still a financial interest of people
that flooded into there to create it
because it was it was it was presented
to them so I'm saying if you like
present a financial incentive to
somebody to recycle plastics whether
through subsidy or whatever like people
will go to it you know incentives fuel
yes that's what I mean like that's why I
think they should have given more
incentives towards like electric car
companies to subsidize those to push
people into that to get it to
profitability yeah
rather than to just be like well cheer
market forces will take care of it
that's yeah that's what I'm basically
talking about like yeah looking at oh
well supply or demand or like you know
it's like a citizen level understanding
or you know how a citizen is affected by
climate change then spurring them to
make a decision in like that route of oh
well we need to wait until there's true
supply and demand and like an economy
yeah but you're never gonna convince
their not gonna can at the end of the
day you're not gonna convince somebody
to like not throw something away sure
unless they either a they're they're
educated to a point where they
understand the decision and the decision
affects them so minimally that it's they
just do it sure or they're they there's
some there's like a recent I think I
think we're on the same page I think
we're on the same page I was just I was
saying that yeah there's this artificial
element that sure has a severe and
dramatic effect on making things change
yeah and and that's true now completely
relying on the you know the capitalism
like the natural capitalist economy to
actually drive it ISM free market forces
that get really messed up when there are
non free market forces outside of the
free market influencing those free
market forces like what you're talking
about it with steel and it'll bit where
the whole like trade war is coming from
I don't know the details of where the
tariffs are going or anything like that
but when China has a steel surplus
because their government is subsidizing
it and steel becomes cheap and everybody
in America starts buying this steel from
China of course all the steel companies
in the US starts struggling and then in
time they can go bankrupt and now
suddenly Chinese government and Chinese
production controls steel in America
yeah and so you have to like well you
might have free market in your country
if another country doesn't have free
market suddenly they are
your free market forces with their
intervention in the market themselves
that's what I'm saying that's why it's
such a comply Casilla the CFC thing is
just an example of that it's it's just
an example of like well yet this is
happening all over the place yeah I mean
but that's gonna happen forever
that's just it so like Earth has one
government do you think do you think an
AI will be a government body at some
point god I hope not I think it might be
the most impartial and fair but in like
a way makes life you know it doesn't
stop when it gets to the neck Nikko it
just goes through a I was responsible as
the governor of all humanity that's
literally what it would do it would just
be like this sucks not necessarily a
good a I ruler would never do such a
good and bad AI Wow all right so now
there's morality okay all right Jake
let's say you were tasked at at I guess
guaranteeing the well very teed
guaranteeing the well-being of hundreds
and millions of people guaranteed all
right
yes you know like this scale well okay
well if you want to make an earth
government billions and I'm just saying
that's a lot of people and when I see
how things are working with social media
and YouTube and what we call the
algorithm and we all are agreeing that
we're working towards this common goal
of trying to get try trying to like
effectively like I guess organize groups
of people on this scale online the
effectiveness though that I see there I
can see being transferred to other parts
so our lives so wait what if the IRS was
just an algorithm here's what I don't
like about that
tell you what I don't like about that's
what I'm talking is that this this whole
concept of algorithm controlling culture
the thing that's the problem with it is
that it doesn't okay let me just state
this and you guys people can hate me for
this but I believe that people are born
equal but as adults are not equal but
that's like the release that's these
algorithmic like thing that's the least
controversial thing you know that's
super controversial people are gonna be
people like think about that that's like
you join me that the life of this person
is not as valuable as the life of this
person and I'm actually saying like if
you're a Secret Service person and you
need to make that decision between like
the president and a crack addict obvious
it's an obvious choice listen to this
but that's not okay people don't think
that and when like this whole like
algorithm drop driven like thing is I
don't know algorithm is because it's
it's this whole like warming world
culture like everyone's it's like okay
I've thought about it like this and it
makes way more sense an algorithm is
just a shared rule set that's
enforceable okay like when we're looking
at the actual like and if you're
actually programming something you're
giving it very clear just decisions to
make
you know if then so does this algorithm
right like if the algorithm has to take
a life okay all I'm saying is that it
does is it gonna treat the President of
the United States under mathematics
equally it'll do what it needs to do
correctly like so what does that mean
correctly but all I'm saying is that
let's say we came up with some a couple
rules five rules for the podcast you
know or something like that or whatever
you know all we have to do is like it
what we can write a constitution here it
says alright this is like the rules that
we're going to abide by but what if we
could take those rules and and and put
it in like the hands of something super
neutral like a computer it's not gonna
be like here's the basically like the
art input based approach it is going
make the exact decision based off of the
rules we have created and we'll be
comparing every action has an equal and
opposite reaction it's like a calculator
that's right for physics it's like a
little fad today if you're talking about
a world government oh gosh bang
headphones if you're talking about a
world government the thing is is as soon
as you do one thing this is YouTube
literally is a great example for this as
soon as they change one remember YouTube
back in the day these two changed stuff
all the time and no one said anything
about it it was just like how they
changed something whatever no now change
oh one button they move one button now
or change it into a different color and
everyone freaks out that has that's
still the same as it's always I don't
know everybody regardless everyone's
freaking out now okay and if you're
talking about a world government that is
run by an algorithm to decide to decide
things for Humanity it's gonna benefit
somebody on one side of the earth and
detriment somebody on the other side of
therefore it's not you can't sit there
and tell me that like it's official
because to to to the world if the world
decides that that the algorithm should
have these five rule sets then as soon
as one rule set is applied people on
this side of the earth are gonna be like
we're pissed because it we applied the
rule set that doesn't know just leave it
to humans because we already at least
we're like used to it if you have a
robot doing ya more energy I guess you
could give a note you can plug them in
very very large difference between an
algorithm or a robot and an AI sorry an
AI super intelligence let's go an AI
super intelligence intelligence it's
like the
go on with it I'm saying is that it in a
superintelligence will have all the same
abilities as the human brain times like
billion mm-hmm so it's like it'll have
all the same levels of empathy and
emotion and all that sort of things that
a human can how can you say that crying
out of one eye and like grimacing with
the other brain is one of the most
complicated things in our entire
universe but it is still a binary
machine at the end of the day you cannot
cannot sit there and tell me that no
matter the intelligence that one species
understands and others because what
you're talking about is a different
species yes let's just leave it at that
yes okay that species will never be able
to understand this species why not
species it's a different species like we
don't understand all the thoughts of
dolphins we don't understand that they
communicate and they're intelligent
actually and I disagree before we get to
understand what it's like to be a
[ __ ] dolphin man aren't we assuming
that all of a sudden these super
intelligent AIS will be able to
understand what it's like to be human
and for empathy and emotion because we
can't we can't understand a little bit
swept off of the table as if like no
humans are humans they'll always be and
nobody else is gonna understand humans
except for humans now we can have tools
that help us inform and make correct
decisions absolutely we should
absolutely develop utilize those in
every way please understand nice and
bacterial very well you are not a yeast
are you are you you're making a case
against a super intelligent AI that runs
the world government right yes you're
arguing against okay I just focus in a
little bit here I'm just saying let's
utilize that have that have have have
super intelligent ai's be the entire
presidential cabinet okay but there's no
probably only gonna be one but don't
make the super intelligent AI also be
the president like let that be a human
it can be informed on all these
different levels by hyper intelligent we
don't really should not have that choice
what does that even mean though once we
have an AI super intelligence we have
lost control is right why don't we just
nitro it it might be bet well if I mean
it's going to be a superior being why
wouldn't we just destroy it that I don't
think it's good I think we really
violent like that why wouldn't we be
what do you mean I don't think humans
have been violent since before weird
comments that's taking of the resources
that we as humans will ultimately fight
for it's like we fight for our own
deaths and I think we will willingly
submit because AI is going to feed us
chocolates and put it sounds like
dystopian communism shake your head I
mean this is literally a fundamental to
the giving away of like the we've been
I'm just gonna go on a little a little
bit um the dog a little rant in your
leash we've been just been bestowed in
the hand of your master a great benefit
with the with the way that the Western
and free free world is and this whole
concept that we should just shuffle it
off without regard because we'll get
chocolates and it'll give us video games
and it'll give us everything we want
that is literally Easter maybe giving
away the selling off of the farm to
whatever else comes in my point is nappy
farmers and so that's what we're gonna
end up getting hopefully that's the
best-case scenario the other scenario is
the Terminator scenario well that means
we just have to be good robot Robo
parents the fact that these are
eventualities currently in an AI arms
race and it is hardcore and it is
heating up and we are trying to make an
AI super intelligence we're still years
away from that but every country every
corporation is trying their hardest to
make the best because they are great
but the moment that that thing runs
humanity we need to destroy it sure we
won't have that ability if it gets to
that point though why not because the AI
will have the ability to see your phone
could electrocute you wherever you are
you'll know where you are rid of all
technology and like walk into the woods
at that point you can there's no one's
gonna want that this is what I mean if
that's true then we were lost as a
culture comforts above overnight this is
gonna be something that evolves over the
next 50 years of course or less most
likely a lot less but like I'm just
saying it's like you know ya know this
but this is inherent in this it sees
maybe this is why I think we've nailed
it guys we've discovered why like things
are like people are so mean to each
other because there's like this inherent
undertone in the sense that nobody knows
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen let's just
competition but you know to all the
computers out there listening I think
you're gonna do a great job when you
grow up I believe in you yeah me too I
got to come find me I'll be in the woods
I've got a can of compressed air with my
gun make your name on it
what the hell's going on with his
headphones I think it's this plug right
here okay yeah well that was a that was
let's talk about AI government some more
in the future yeah speaking can I bring
up one thing that's actually right in
line with this last last week the city
of Baltimore was had a cyber attack done
on it and as far as I understand the
city services that are run currently
online are all currently shut down like
what like like DMV registrations yes
like DMV registration home registration
like when buying and selling property
and a bunch of other things and
apparently there that was done by
hackers and the hackers have demanded 13
bitcoins this has happened in more than
20 municipalities this year and it
happened to the city of Atlanta in March
last year and it cost 17 million dollars
to for them to recover well so how did
they I wonder what they do they score
sure so is this the years way of warfare
amongst people yeah but you know like
we'll just shut down your AI super
intelligence and all of a sudden you
don't have a president is that what this
is going to my a I will be eerily i I'm
serious it's like a bumper sticker but
yes it would that be a cool movie we're
just fighting each other just plug two
computers in and just like they sit
there and then like one just turns off
[Laughter]
two towers just running at full capacity
yeah it turns on it's the same operating
system as the other one oh god no I
don't know I think I think it's good for
everybody to reminded to keep their
servers up-to-date and actually do a
good job with the security like I think
these little so the ransomware attacks
are a good reminder to like not be dumb
when setting up your computers right and
all that do it perpetrate that as their
justification for I'm sorry so I mean
the hospital that my wife Jenna used to
work at she's a nurse a few years ago
got hit with one of these ransomware
things where they stole all the medical
records and locked them out of the
system and they demanded a bunch of
Bitcoin to get it back right
I forget how that ended up getting
resolved and they're probably they
that's what I'm saying they probably
tell them self well if I do this attack
it'll strengthen their security so I'm
actually doing humanity a favor
well that isn't that was between that
white hat black hat and a hacker like a
white hat hacker is somebody who is
hacking you just to show that they can
hack you and they'll help you versus
like a black hat hackers like their to
think the only hat that they should have
is a full metal jacket
[Laughter]
I'm gonna hack you but I'll give it all
back everyone I remember when studious
anyone got hacked and our channel had
like all the names changed yeah that was
supposedly a white hat hack sure let's
call it that I think it changes from a
white hat to a black hat the moment you
demand money or something like
definitely ransom alright
last topic guys is the American flag too
big there's an RV dealership at a city
in North Carolina that has a 40 by 80
foot US flag which is commonly seen like
in parts of the nation but apparently
the city says that this flag is twice as
big as city regulations allow for signs
and other art doe marketing devices and
they're charging them $50 a day until
they take it down sorry the ship says
they'll never take it down there's a
limitation on signs and marketing
devices yes so apparently this is the
question this is the question there
they're saying that it's a sign that
that it's signage and then other people
are saying no it's not signage it's the
American flag people are using their
eyes yeah now they're also trying to say
that there's like a time place manner
restriction where it's too close to the
freeway so it needs to be a certain size
because of that but it does come down to
like the fact that the city is saying
that they gave them a permit to fly the
flag and that the flag is too big in
accordance with the permit this sounds
like a bunch of people taken advantage
of public outcry to make some money in
PR and advertising yes I think Niko
nailed it
and they're using that American flag for
dollars guys are making money off their
RV site without American flag but
they're disguising it as patriotism dude
you know that I that I can't stand
honestly like I know people I don't know
if these people are doing that but when
people do that and they utilize
patriotism in that way to like say if
you don't have an American flag tattooed
across your back boy
you can get the hell out like that's
just not I think yeah I believe that
these guys aren't doing it intentionally
they just want to have it they probably
just put out a huge fire absolutely
taking advantage of this already that's
been presented you know how I know I
should cuz there's a picture of a tweet
from the guy with a blue checkmark next
to his name if he gave a crap and it
wasn't for money he wouldn't be tweeting
about it making a statement to get some
attention because that doesn't matter if
you actually give a crap about what
you're doing
you don't need a tweet about it to get
validation is just yeah I hate Twitter
it's true I hate Twitter too yeah I
don't use it Ren you use it oh yeah I'm
a big fan of Twitter so what do you like
about it you know I'm just I'm just
asking you what you like about it I'm
not judging
I enjoy the the community it's it's a
really good way to reach out and talk
with people that's true it's you know
it's it's it has its pros and cons like
everything else in life I will say I
don't like the idea of I mean this isn't
really a Twitter thing this is just a
human discourse thing I don't like the
idea of people shouting at each other
and like little quippy sound bites yeah
it's like shouting it's like shouting at
somebody on the street as you drive by
in your car yeah yeah that's why I
stopped using it it's just like I there
was the discussions were really toxic
and it can be that's why I stopped using
it I just bailed out I do like the
accessibility and the ease of
communication provides now do you think
that like kids these days growing up are
going to just be used to like things
being toxic online and like there being
just thousands of just unverified news
sources and just noise or do you think
culture is gonna change and that's gonna
get fixed I think culture is gonna
change yeah I yeah I I do feel like
we're working on it new is incredibly
new yeah like social media as a thing
has barely been around for more than 15
years but there is an inherent thing
where now like and this might change too
but now like especially younger kids
they're equated our self-worth with how
many followers they have and that's just
messed up I think you know and like I
don't know what the answer to that is
but I do know that that doesn't seem
right Sam Jake I have a question for you
guys think this should be our wrap-up
okay how old will your kids be before
you give them their first cell phone
know how old we're kids before you give
them their first smartphone okay yeah
that's a different question because I'll
probably give my kid a flip phone just
so that they can call me when they're
like no their own their own phone number
probably not until they're like I don't
know I mean this is a subjective
question it depends on their maturity it
depends on their friends it depends on
like all these different factors right
that you have to judge as a parent in
the moment but probably like somewhere
between the age of like thirteen and
sixteen
Wow that's old that's a smart phone my
my first my first answer I didn't get a
smart phone until I was well they didn't
allow this but I got a phone I didn't
get a phone until I was like I online my
first answer was gonna be 13 14 huh I
was 13 when I got my first cell phone
yeah the average age now is 9 right I
think that's too young for a smartphone
that's too like I'll give my kid a flip
phone so they can call me or but by the
end we'll just have little watches they
already have them yeah they're 9 years
old Jake Paul happens guys they wait for
tonight wait that's what will happen oh
man
I'm stopped by not giving your kids
smartphones in the 90s that's too young
I think it's just there's too much
toxicity out there and at that age
you're barely at a point where you're
understanding like right and wrong ya
know from like a you know like a real
point of view and and when even when
you're like 16 you think you know but
you don't
something like looking back an old post
he wrote when you're in high school on
the forum and just pick smeissen one of
my favorite posts this days when Sam was
selling an airsoft gun on eBay and
somebody was disappointed with his
salesmanship you're dumb you're dumb
old sandwich of what you think about
social media like the fact is is that I
you know was relatively computer savvy
as a young from a young age and so in
elementary school no no - what year 2000
what was the junior high high school
would have been 14 yeah yeah so I I got
my eBay account when I was like in
eighth grade yeah so yeah I was doing he
deals they were dealing with like a like
a four-game deal 14-year old so now you
have a now you have a smartphone
under the current I know hypothesis this
is what I'm saying social media aside
there's still plenty of like damage a
fourteen-year-old kid can do oh yeah you
know yeah you know you think you heard
that person's feelings I hope so I have
no idea see I remember they're like you
had a paper route and you'd have like
disposable income of like a hundred
dollars a month which is a lot of money
that was a lot for a kid in junior high
remember you buy like a mansion goggle
there's no scope and now super cool but
course only fun for like a week yep
sounds like there's this thing called
eBay you just sell it
I can sold it for the same amount of
money I bought it for I'm gonna buy a
guitar I sold that guitar was save my
money about it for now we buy a
Playstation 2 and Sam just cycle through
these things and Mike for like six
dollars to God in Australia yeah and
also took just like photos of like
random stuff on my desk and I like tried
to sell it oh my god we could try it we
should mmm and I put it in an envelope
and
like truly they post things we're still
so fresh back then Sam was way ahead of
the curb good times
want me to try the trade up system have
you heard about the guy who traded his
way up from a paperclip to a house yes
yeah in a pre pre or of HTML internet
legend but is the trade system not
really just you being a courier making
money as a courier courier that career
having everything in life is like we're
all currently oh I have this milk you
want milk and you'll you'll pay me and
just giving me something slightly worth
more in the milk for me to carry it to
you you're just adding value and the
fact that yours transporting things
you're a courier good point yeah I mean
that's almost all that's retail
arbitrage so the guy who trade buy
something for less than what you sell it
for
he's like a delivery boy with no like
destination basic exactly I just wanna
say you guys check out your Nobel you
guys should definitely check out bash
brothers and Netflix also catch-22 on
Hulu it's really good it's good yeah
finest guys I am really really happy
about the shirts and all the stuff on
the store because it is super super my
body too coming together it's like
really really really really good stuff
and this is coming from a guy who we
sold t-shirts that weren't honestly not
that great for a few months they're like
in like the company we were working with
previously just was not holding it up
and finally they're not as good as these
I'm just talking the overall quality of
some of the older stuff we sold first we
did our best at the time though it's not
only did intentionally tried to make
shitty of course not of course not no
yeah there's things that were
in America yeah it's actually for that
companies a different yeah but you want
to say you guys probably know if you're
looking this podcast that our clothing
sells out pretty quickly if you're
listening to this podcast you are the
first to know about this by the way
that's true Saturday is the big
announcement this is coming out on
Friday so you have a day before
everybody else gotta buy the stuff and
we have like a couple hundred of each of
these so you want it go get it right so
it's gonna be live this merchandise will
be live a couple hours before the video
drops on Saturday and the video is
probably gonna drop at what 10 a.m. 10
a.m. so most stuff will be live
immediately yeah probably around either
late Friday night or really early
Saturday morning yeah we'll see if
you're listening to this podcast just
hit that merch store link in the bottom
and head on over
yeah all right cool thanks for listening
thanks poising everybody please
subscribe if you have not subscribed and
you can of course listen to this podcast
everywhere you can find podcasts yeah
yeah boom signing out check out the
guillotine channel coming to